you know it's an amazing story Stephen
Stills and I agree with you that he is
one of the most underrated guitar
players I find him unbelievable even
when he did his solo work but Joni
Mitchell wrote the song Woodstock indeed
she was upset right that she didn't get
to go to Woodstock well she was supposed
to go right you know but she also would
stop finished on the Sunday she was
supposed to do the Dick Cavett show on
Monday and it was a very important TV
show for her her biggest entry into TV
world right yeah but then when 20,000
people are coming 50,000 people were
coming a hundred thousand people coming
half a million people are coming Elliot
and Geffen didn't think she'd be able to
get out of there to do the TV show and
they were worried about that so that
killed her and she decided that's it I'm
writing this song Woodstock but the
getting to my point about Stephen Stills
when he heard this song yes he said he
said Joan can I use that song well of
course she said because can I change it
and he turned it into the great rock and
roll song that it is he really did
Stephen Stills heard this song and knew
how to arrange it to make it a hit and
that's isn't it it is even he took
someone else's song this is one of the
best crosby stills in their songs of all
time I think
they pause
still holds up for me - oh I love it I
love you feel about it
Joanie must have loved it I think she
did because I'm yeah you know it took
her song which was a light dark purpley
kind of song until the end or balls-out
rock'n'roll song